wendy williams putting her health first
we've got a lot to talk about we've
learned she's seeking professional
treatment ahead of her self-proclaimed
comeback
they don't know how to count me out a
rep for the former talk show host tells
e.t
wendy's entered a quote wellness
facility
while there's no details about what kind
of facility wendy's checked into
i feel
like everybody deserves
privacy according to her rep wendy's
quote seeking help to manage her overall
health issues
and quote being treated by a team of
some of the best doctors in the world
you know you got to take care of your
kids and you have to take care of your
health and you have to take care of your
job
the move is part of her career's next
chapter after her talk show went off the
air in june following a full season
without the host at the hill
i'm really going to miss the show
mr president
you know she's unique you know there's
no other
quote she is taking some time to focus
on her health and wellness as she
prepares for a major comeback and a
major stepping stone in her comeback a
possible return to her radio days
kind of
with the windy experience podcast
co-host i'm famous and i'll be back
trust me which she's been teasing for
months but has yet to materialize amid
erratic behavior from the star
like claiming she got married
no everybody seems to have a problem
with that i'm married
i'm married i don't care who knows it
i'm married
the rep adds quote we ask for your
prayers and well wishes during this time
the news comes in the aftermath of a
tumultuous year for the tv icon
please let me have access to my money
this is not right and again this is not
fair in june she said goodbye to the
wendy williams show but wendy wasn't
part of its 13th and final season
she previously stepped back from her
daytime gig amid her various health
issues
fast forward to last month former
staffers of the show opened up to the
hollywood reporter describing wendy's
chaotic final days behind the scenes
it's weird doing hot topics and being a
hot topic you know what i mean and i
think that there's nobody involved with
wendy williams show that was happy about
the way it ended after the season 13
start date got delayed executives
reportedly attempted to put wendy on a
zoom call with the staff
and it did not go well
many people described a scenario where
she was sort of rambling she sort of
became incoherent it was very clear to
everybody watching that she wasn't fine
and that she wasn't going to sort of be
back at the show anytime soon show
sources claimed producers sent at least
25 pre-show text messages to higher-ups
questioning wendy's sobriety during her
last four years
citing details like staffers finding
quote bottles of alcohol up in the
ceiling tiles
the concerns about her health
are vast this was a show that had been
on the air for 13 years
there was a love for
wendy herself sherry shepard gets hosted
several times on the series y'all doing
better than me
there we go the comedian later took over
wendy's time slot with a talk show of
her own she too expressed worry for
wendy's well-being
she's going through a lot i would say
that everybody should be praying for
wendy right now i'm very concerned
[Music]
you